for those who are absolute newbies and
and you want a more introduction to
python and how python handles data and
how we are going to load data into
python so we have excellent resources in
our mixed logics platform so you should
definitely check that out before
venturing into uh
yeah such a
more specialized workshop so now
let's go over this with the help of the
cola that we built and you can of course
run this and i will explain it to you
what each and every lion will actually
do due to
some limitations in the time so we will
go over them one by one and in some
specific areas i would break down the
code and then explain it to you what
each and every one of these
parameters and these
functions and the different ones um
handle the data
and yeah so
if at the end of today's
sessions if you still think you you are
still short on
getting the basics about how the data
has been handled then please check out
the
resources that we mentioned and they're
linked and you should have very good
solid understanding after that and then
if you come back to this
recording or these cola then you will be
able to work with this uh much better so
let me also open up my chat box
yeah okay that's good
i am on the way so how many of you know
how to work with the collab so this is a
collab that we are going to share it
with you and if you want to run it you
can actually
take a make a copy of this one
please change the access level from
restricted to
viewer so that they can actually see
them
okay okay now you can see
[Music]
yes
yes okay great thank you very much
okay so this is a collab if
if you want to save the changes that you
are going to make
and
for better organization i think i would
suggest you to open this up in after
signing into google
involve uploading it no no there is no
uploading of any programs here you just
can if you have a google account you can
straight away run this start running
this
right make a copy after going to file
you can choose this save a copy in drive
so you can do this so that you can save
a copy of this collaboratory notebook in
your google drive so you can make
changes and then
work on that on your version of the same
information and same collab that we have
prepared for it
so if everybody had made a copy then
that will be great and let please let me
know quickly in the chat box that if you
had met up if you have made a copy of
this and we will go over this quickly
okay excellent so let's let's uh we have
some introduction and elia covered most
of them uh about how what we are going
to do and about little bit uh about the
data set also so let's uh
programmatically go over the dataset so
first we have to load some of the
modules and libraries and people who are
familiar with python would know that we
have
very useful modules and libraries like
pandas numpy psychic and we we will be
using many of these today and
so we load these libraries and then we
have to mention where to find the data
this data link that we are mentioning
can be from your local computer if you
are running a
running python in your local computer
can be from your local computer or it
can be from
publicly available resources or from
from github or other resources that you
can access the data the main
bottle like this you should get clean
access to the data and then comes how to
load the data so once we have
established where the data is so this
object or variable points to where the
data is so now we have to load the data
so what is this actually does um
before that i i just assume that
everybody knows how to run with the
collab so if you are new
and if you don't know how to work with
the collab on this area where i'm seeing
a green symbol you should see a connect
button right it should tell connect and
please click on the connect so that it
will uh google can allocate you some uh
resources you can use it for executing
these python groups and after that you
can run all the codes
what repository in collaboration should
i use just use this one uh you you don't
i don't think that that's a specific
question
just start using this one if if it is
not letting you use maybe i think you
should set up collab first i think i
don't need it's necessary it will
automatically set it up just click yes
yes yes and go
and once you have connected you will
you'll find this small
play button like boxes which will help
you execute this
box of block of code
indicate properly with pointer so after
we click connect what will be the next
option to choose so you can come down
scroll down so you have text uh
information as we can see here and
yes this will be applicable to jupiter
you can download and then load it in the
jupyter notebook also but the difference
is you have to
install python and require libraries and
modules in your local computer
so this is a code block which you can
see that you can play or execute a code
block or in another word you can run the
cell right and that will actually
execute all the commands that is that is
that we have entered into this code
block so that is what we are going to do
right execute these commands line by
line and and get get an understanding of
what these commands commands are doing
to the data and how we are achieving our
goal of exploring the data so first um
we are trying to understand the patterns
in the data through some basic
exploratory analysis so that is what you
should do so i think if that part is
clear so let's everybody start
executing the first block if you execute
this first block
so you should see this output
do you see this output
so if you see this output let's break
down this these codes a little bit
little and find what we are actually
doing
do you see this see this output
so what we have done we have done loaded
some modules we have pointed to where
the data link is and then we have
loaded the data into an object that
object is a data frame so that is what
we have done and then we displayed first
few lines of this data frame so is
everybody here just just the first block
you can run this by clicking this run
cell option okay so what this does is
this function pandas or pd.read.table
right
you don't have to add any packages uh
mitra i think yeah so in this one first
you have to
let
python know where is your information
where is your data where is your fight
so that is that is covered by this data
link so we have pointed uh where the
file is and then we have to describe at
least some of the characteristics of the
file so that the data can be loaded
accurately so one of the important
characteristics is
if the file is organized as column wise
and row wise that's what we are going to
use
uh why do we want to use that i think
this is going to be an exploratory uh
code introduction to you so if you can
develop on this code then you can maybe
put it up in the kaggle computation i
think this data is not not in any
competition right now so after
understanding what you're going to do
you can
work on this on your own
okay let's find
can ah
so nalika somebody share the cola blink
one more time
or save it somewhere where you can
retrieve and yeah
okay thank you iman thank you i think
she got it here
so yes so what we have to describe the
data so we mentioned that the data is
organized by uh in in a comma separated
version format where each and every
column is separated by the character
comma and we also mentioned the first
line of the
data is a uh contains header information
sometimes they won't when if if it has
information we need it we need to be
that needed to be mentioned and that's
all
is necessary and then this can be
saved or stored into an object that is
data frame that we have named as tf and
we can display the first few lines of
the df by using df.head command so come
down i'm going to open up another code
which is going to give you and let me
explore a little bit more about the data
frame that we just loaded right you can
open up another code by
using this block or using this block
here so let's do
that there are functional differences
between let's stick to what i'm actually
telling you so a very specific questions
like what is the difference between two
functions and other things can be had
later so there are options like read
underscore table and table and
read the csv
have a different preferences to their to
their default values right that's that's
what and
so let's see um here let's see in the df
we can
find out how big is our data
right using df shape so we might we see
that it is 320 almost 320 000 records or
320 000 rows and we have 18 columns
in our data and what are our columns
that also we can find out
we get a we get a sneak peek of this
right you can scroll all the way to the
left and you get all the columns
mentioned here sometimes when you have a
lot of columns in the case of or working
with
a long i mean um more feature uh data
then you will not see all of these
columns then you can type df dot info
right info would uh will actually give
you and not social information yeah here
we have it here so anyway so info
[Music]
will actually tell you what are the
columns that we have and what type of
data that those columns possess right we
can see that we have except for one two
three and four of our columns all the
other columns are uh in the object data
type or they contain non-numeric uh
entries in their uh
values in their as their entries and
four of those are float are they there
numeric data with significant values so
that is what those are the information
that we get from uh this
info
right pattern
you have not loaded this file
uh loaded this cell run this execute
this then the name df would be defined
and glory you should be all set
the data set is also in here
in this first block
if you execute this then you should be
good to go i hope everybody is here with
this display and then later if you type
df shape df info you'll be here
so
hope everybody gotten this df info
information about your columns
yes okay let's move on
okay so what else are we going to do
with this one so we have four of our
columns and then we can
find out some of the summary or some
numerical
summary summarization of the information
that we find in the appropriate
numerical column one is bmi and we have
physical health mental health and then
we have sleep time so a simple df
describe right
describe
option
if you run this then you should get some
numbers
and that and those numbers are properly
annotated here first it actually counts
uh how many parameter or how many values
entries do we have and then we get the
central tendency mean and then standard
deviation and we get minimum to maximum
once uh and
our quantile values the fifty percent
electron is the median and yeah we have
our quantile values and
statistical description or summary of
our data so everybody got this
is everybody here described
has everybody got into the summary of
the data let's let's quickly go so okay
this is this is good to uh
because we have a lot of numbers and lot
of information but if you want to
present or if you want to have a
good visual
output then we can beautify this further
right
that's what we want to do next so this
is the this is the output that you saw
earlier presented today so what we have
done from here to here we will break
down this code and then
uh in the beginning we'll take it slowly
and then after after a while we will
just breathe through so what we have
done here
this is the option and uh let's open up
another code so df.describe
tells that and and then adding
a range
tells what is the necessary information
that i need to consider i don't want the
count right we already know that how
many uh how many uh different rows that
we have from our previous analysis i
don't want the count to be mentioned
here so i am taking the values only from
one right
pythons counting always start free
your outlier describe is different
because you have not used the bracket
if you use the bracket your out
outline
output of this drive will not be
different
[Music]
yeah so
we don't need the count data or we don't
need to count the number of rows that we
already know so i'm leaving that out
python always starts from python's
indices or index always starts from zero
so your your array number your
matrix uh counts everything starts from
zero so now i don't want that so i'm
leaving that 0 out so i start from 1. so
in the mean i'm transposing the data so
that is little bit presentable
instead of going through like this i
want
my
features to be listed in the rows column
and then their characteristics on the
column so that's what this one tells and
what do i need to call them right we can
name what do i need to call them by this
right that's what it is doing and
and then i'm transposing the data that's
what t does right t transposes the data
if you just leave it at this point
right at these specific separate points
you can leave this
right we can leave at this point it's
going to tell or leave out the counter
information and then print out the same
and then uh you can leave it
in
this
and that's going to name them exactly
the way that you want bmi physical
health and mental health so we just
copied the name exactly the same way but
if your
column names are not very appropriate or
has num some special character not
special writers has some numbers and and
no capitalization so this is where you
will you can use it to rename that right
and then we transpose it and that's good
to go
and then we add some beautification
touches like we can actually style the
color cell in a gradient
of reds or blues or greens whatever
color that you want to color it from so
this gives you a good uh range right
for each and every
column so we have the least uh values
that are in occupying least rates and
most value occupied when most right so
we get a um
so we get a good number or uh yeah we
get a good comparison right uh which of
this four
out of which of these four parameters
what is the use of cmap it's a color map
it's for styling color map is a full
form of cmap right it's a map to
yeah not for different color right
so uh out of the different comparisons
for the means uh bmi has the highest
mean of course it is expected and the
other parameters are uh we can have this
here
so we can come down and then for example
uh
this is an overall summary right we have
some categorical columns a lot of
categorical columns as well so why do i
call categorical columns if you go there
you can see then they have they take
some specific entries or specific values
smoking takes yes or no and um sex takes
male or female and this is not a
categorical column but uh yeah and
we go here
general health takes uh from somewhere
between good fair very good they had
they have some specific set of
entries that they are taking right so we
can take those categorical columns and
count the number of entries that we have
for example in this case and how many of
them are white and how many of them are
african-american and how many of them
are from different different race so we
can count that and then make a uh um or
calculate the percentage of the
counts right
and how many of them are male and how
many of them are female so we can get a
distribution of different percentage of
categorical
columns or categorical features as we
should say because we are exploring this
in the data frame data science point of
view
we have so that is what we can do here
and how to count so we can use the
inbuilt value counts function which is
going to count for example let's do that
in this
count
option so if everybody is here
if everybody is here i'm going to
destroy i'm going to demonstrate you
what it actually does
i'm commenting out the second option
second line and when i run this
you will get different count for yes and
different no
right
for those who has heart disease we have
uh
we have about only 27 000 of those
people who has heart disease and almost
30
300 000 290 000 of people they do not
have any heart disease that's what these
value counts do and then uh just by
getting these numbers we can actually
divide this by the total number of these
counts to get their percent get their
percentage so that's uh that's our goal
to get percentage-wise distribution of
each and every one of these uh
categorical column how do we get that uh
we can use both right value dot counts
thus uh they count each and every
individual so i want you to try in the
next code right copy this
quickly copy this
and paste it here and go up here what's
the interesting account that we can find
out uh where is this general health
somebody can do for general health and
someone else someone else can do for
race and paste your entries in the code
here so um what do we want you to do
leave out this part
right you have to maintain the
capitalization right
general
health and someone else can do race
quickly paste the entries in the comment
run for these differently
right if you did not match the
capitalization it will not work
do we have it here
great excellent
yes that's for race
so now you get the hang of it anybody
did it for general health